thank you for joining us at microsoft
research summit 2021 my name is
copenhagen from georgetown university
and my talk title is towards bridging
between legal and technical approaches
to their protection
this is based on joint work with micah
altman alona korean and alex wood
so more and more decisions of little
nature are made in computer systems
maybe the first example that has been
with us for me for many years is credit
score
and this score provides an assessment of
the potential risk that the consumer
possesses the score is calculated by
credit bureaus that collect a lot of
financial information
and is used in a variety of financial
decisions by banks lenders and some
other transactions also a second example
is uh the tools that were developed
these are machine learning tools
that were developed to assist legal
decision making by judges uh probation
officers and so on and a couple of
examples is predicting risk of
recidivism and predicting failure to
appear in court and this definitely have
potential consequences to
defendants
and more generally we are all exposed to
personalization all the time through
targeted behavioral advertising
personalized recommendations
um and and so on and all these
applications raise and all the time
uh worries about privacy risks
surveillance discrimination manipulation
and a little more
but all these applications are built
from simpler and maybe
mundane looking building
blocks there are built up decisions on
the collection storage deletion
processing and sharing of personal
information
and the number of such operations is
just huge i don't know exactly how many
decisions are made daily but clearly are
a lot of them and these are mostly
opaque to users to experts into policy
makers and this is in spite
of the regulation
addressing some of this decision at
least to
some extent and definitely the more
modern regulations like the general data
protection regulation in the eu the
california consumer protection or the
california privacy rights act and we're
likely to see some
other
regulations like that in the near future
so the question is whether we can make
sure that these decisions that are made
in computer science systems where they
agree
with the legal digital and the legal
requirements
and i want to say that this is important
not only for compliance compliance is
often an easier question
because
for compliance officers can claim that
they are using the
best technologies at the time and so on
but it's really important that we would
understand the relationship between the
disease rata that is expressed in legal
data protection standards and the actual
protection that is provided
by the technology that we use
and there are many challenges towards
this and maybe the most basic ones are
definitional challenges
so from now on i'm going to focus on
privacy and privacy is a their
protection concept
that has emerged
uh in legal philosophical
uh thinking in the social sciences and
so on
but it also has a technical
uh face so
privacy has this kind of dual nature
and on the technical side if we think of
how we deal with privacy uh we have come
up with uh concepts like encryptions
your knowledge sequematipatic
computation differential privacy and
many more and these are concepts that
are defined using precise rigorous
mathematical formulations
they leave no gray areas a system is
either
an encryption system or not either it is
provides your knowledge or not and so on
um
and we reason about these systems and
about the concepts using mathematical
language so on the technical side we're
trying to be very precise
and very crisp
on the other hand
when we look at legal standards of
privacy we see a collection of other
concepts maybe the most important is
private
uh identifiable information
and we also see other concepts like the
identification anonymization linkability
inference risks statistical purposes opt
out their deletion consent and quite a
few more
and these the definitions of these
concepts many leave
a lot to be uh queried there are many
great areas they are not precise for a
mathematical standpoint
and even more so sometimes the little
the rata seems in disagreement
with our current scientific and
technical understanding
so a question is how
we can breach these really big
differences
so i'd like to mention some relevant
work in this direction
in 2005 hellenistenbaum presented the
framework of contextual integrity it's
an interesting framework that combines
technical
and
normative notions it speaks about norms
as privacy as norms
about information flow between contexts
it is not defined using mathematical
language it's not mathematically precise
but there were attempts to formulate
aspects of contextual integrity in logic
in particular this uh worked by barthel
jumping in a few years ahead and
mentioned work we did at harvard on the
fair path
is a legal standard this is the family
educational rights and privacy act
and
we
formalized
uh the privacy standards trying to
answer a question whether
a concept that we were working with
differential privacy whether the use of
differential privacy satisfies the
requirements of ferpa
in this work we observed quite a few
gaps
between the technical and legal
approaches and in paper with alex wood
we
wrote about today's
gaps and the challenges
that
they pose
worked by alanikon national park
followed by sarah scheffler and
mayank varya
uh is on compel decryption and foregone
conclusion
uh the question here is when can the
government compel individuals to decrypt
their information according to the
foregone conclusion doctrine this is a
doctrine
that says
that
information is a conclusion is forgotten
if the compelled information adds little
or nothing to the sum of total
central of the government's information
and they use
paradigms from cryptography in their
definitions
the right to be forgotten and more
generally there are deletion was
addressed in a work by gargital
and
in the work by aloni curran and letters
mark altman and alex wood we discussed a
notion from the gtbr signaling out that
i'm going to focus on
uh in a few
minutes so this is the structure of the
talk uh we're going to focus on the
modeling and mathematical modeling of a
legal concept and then we would apply
the model in what i would call legal
theorems
before that we're gonna have a british
background so we i will introduce a few
concepts and then we'll end with a
summary and the two concepts will begin
with our county and differential privacy
so let me present
it's a concept that was
uh
developed by samarati in sweden
and the idea is
as in this picture we have data
collected about individuals
and via suppression
and generalization
we make sure that any combination of
potentially identifying attributes like
in the picture appears at least k times
so in the picture we see an example of a
two anonymized data set on the left we
see the original data on the right we
see the two anonymized version
so now uh i cannot tell whether my
neighbor from zip code 23456
had a heart disease or viral disease so
some privacy may be preserved
it's a very natural concept it's easy to
understand and it follows a
class of attacks that is called linkage
attacks
um many regulations seems to create
privacy and anonymity and cal nimity
seems to work well with these
regulations
but
people have uh
identified weaknesses in the concert and
in particular
homogeneity attacks background attacks
and very importantly composition attacks
second concept i want to present is
differential privacy it's a concept that
was developed by cincinnati ward
sherry myself and adam smith in 2006
and
these this concept involves uh
it's a requirement on analysis and to
understand it we will
we will compare what happens in what i
will call an ideal world a privacy idea
world and the real world
so think about my privacy ideal world my
information here is not included in the
analysis
so the analysis is performed and there
is an outcome to the analysis but
without my information hence i think
that my privacy
is not at risk at least in some
particular sense
in the real world my information is
included in the hana in the analysis
hence i'm potentially at risk
and differential privacy requires that
the outcome
outcomes in the ideal and the real world
would be in some sense similar there is
a parameter epsilon for measuring this
similarity
and the idea is that
if epsilon if the similarity is very
high
epsilon is very low
um
then
what happens in
the real world is very similar to what
happens in my ideal world because my
privacy is preserved in the ideal world
it would also be preserved in the real
world
okay this can be formulated
mathematically i'm not going to get into
the language here
um i just want to say that differential
privacy was shown to allow a variety of
computations like descriptive statistics
machine learning tasks
synthetic data generation and and a lot
more
um it's a mathematical concept so
mathematicians computer scientists can
reason about it
using the tools that they have but it's
not so easy to explain and we don't
uh yet understand well how
it relates to concepts uh in uh coming
from legal standards of privacy
so i'm getting to the main uh part of
the presentation where we'll discuss the
modeling of a legal concept we'll begin
with the concepts from the gdpr the
general data protection regulation which
is called signaling out
and we will develop a technical concept
which in which we will call predicate
signal signaling out we will not claim
that they are the same the modeling will
not achieve singling out exactly
but will uh
still claim that this modeling is useful
so let's read from the gdpr
article one of the standards says this
regulation lays down rules relating to
the protection of natural persons with
regard to the processing of personal
data in article 4
it explains that personal data means any
information relating to an identified or
identifiable natural person directly or
indirectly
and furthermore in recital 26 there is
an explanation to determine whether
natural person is identifiable account
should be taken of all the means
reasonably likely to be used such as
singling out to identify the natural
person directly or indirectly so from
these pieces of text we can learn that
if you can signal out in the data then
the data is identifiable and hence this
is personal data and other the preview
of the
gdpr
now there is no
explanation in gdpr of what singling out
means but we have uh
guidance documents by the article 29
working party that was set up for the
data protection directive that preceded
the gdpr the gdpr
this group produced opinions
recommendations and reports providing
expert opinion and guidelines on the
interpretation of the
dpd requirements
it was replaced by the european their
protection born in 2018
and here's what they say they say as
regards indirectly identified or
identifiable persons this category
typically relates to the phenomenon of
unique combinations whether small or
large in size a name itself
may not
may not be necessary in all cases to
indeed identify individual this may
happen when other identifiers are used
to single someone out
and furthermore in another document the
uh working party compared
various technologies drafts privacy
technology in particular anonymity and
differential privacy and asking what a
signaling out remains a risk with
respect to canon limited they said no
with respect to differential privacy
they say i may not
so let's
think about this concept and whether we
can uh uh define it mathematically and
something that is very natural also
seems to follow very well the guidelines
of the article 29 working party is to
identify singling out as isolation let
me say what i mean by that but to
present the analysis i would like first
to present it a first a simple model
okay
so we would assume that we have a data
set that uh contains record randomly
sampled uh from some underlying
distribution think about if uh the
concept of a probability distribution is
it is not familiar thinking about it as
sampling from a large population
then this data set is fed into an
anonymization mechanism and the
mechanism outputs some outcome whether
this is a and can anonymized
their state or the outcome of
statistical analysis
uh what not
and this is given to an adversary this
is the singling out adversary and the
adversary is going to output a
description a predicate on the records
for instance
uh
somebody who's doing a theoretical
computer science like me and told
the adversary's goal is given the output
of the mechanism to create a predicate
that matches exactly one row in x this
is what we call isolation and here is
our definitional attempt
we say that the anonymization mechanism
m is secure against signaling out if no
adversary can isolate a row
except with very very tiny probability
and this is over all the relevant
randomness in this uh in this process
and this looks very intuitive until you
begin examining this idea and you find
out that it is either impossible or at
least very problematic and let me show
why
i'll show it by an example think about
in trivial adversary so the trivial
adversary does not get
any outcome from an immunization
mechanism okay so if the rebel adversary
would manage to isolate in the data
we cannot claim that this is because of
the output it got from the anonymization
mechanism simply did not get that
so here's an example assume the dataset
contains 365 random birth dates okay and
the and the singling out adversary knows
that but nothing more
signaling out obviously could output a
predicate like born on october 23rd okay
an expectation this this agrees with the
description of one person in the in the
data set but the adversary does not know
whether that is the case or not
but and
a simple calculation
uh gives that the adversary does manage
to isolate a row in the data set with
probability
uh 37
which is quite high so maybe if the
adversary tries three times with three
different data sets
then in the atmosphere would be likely
to succeed at least once
um
so this uh trivial isolation is a
problem for the previous definition and
we need to uh fix it i want to say that
this is just an example
which we can generalize all that is
needed is that the data set x is sampled
from a distribution that has enough
uncertainty enough variety
which is
the um
the common case
so we want to
fix this notion of singling out as
isolation and what we will ask is when
is it the case that isolation
is actually interesting it's non-trivial
okay
and here is the idea
signaling out happens when
uh i a manages to isolate with um
probability that is significantly uh
higher than the baseline let me give you
a couple of examples for instance
continuing with the data set with
365 birthdates and the predicate worn on
october 23rd
we saw that
even without getting any access to to
the outcome of the anonymizing mechanism
um an attacker can succeed in isolating
with uh high probability 37 percent
so this is not uh impressive if an
attacker claims that this is what they
can do but if the attacker actually
succeeds with much higher probability to
isolate let's say 99
then this seems non-trivial
and maybe in the other direction we fix
here a a
a description
that is so specific that it's likely
that no person on earth actually
satisfies this description
now if the attacker succeeds with uh
descriptions that are so unlikely even
with a small probability like one
percent
then we would say that this this is
non-trivial
so this brings us to the definition that
we call security against predicate
signaling out so again we're not
claiming that this exactly models
signaling out from the gdpr but a
concept that is related to it and we'll
examine that relationship in a few
slides
okay so this is the definition and
informal and simplified we say that the
mechanism m is secure against predicate
singling out attacks
if there's not if for no uh
distribution d and no
adversary a
it is the case that a isolates
with a description that is extremely
extremely extremely rare and succeed in
doing that with
non-negligible probability
now this may sound too strong and one of
the things to do hence is to see whether
this definition allows any kind of
utility
from the data and it it is the case that
we can extract utility and maybe the
most basic uh statistical
uh query is a count query
and here's the mechanism uh
g is a description uh the mechanism
counts the number of rows in the
database x that fit the description g
and um for instance how many people in
dataset are diabetic
and we can prove mathematically
that uh this mechanism actually it's a
family of mechanism
and they are all predicate signaling out
secure
and we can do that with a few other
simple uh kind of mechanism
now
once we have a mathematical definition
of the concept the definition itself is
also a mathematical object and we can
ask questions about it
and one very important question to ask
is whether
uh uh predicate singling out
self-composers well it is the case
that if we have a collection of uh
mechanisms each
secure against predicate signaling out
what happens if we look at all of them
as one big mechanism is that still uh
secure
and
with alonicon we prove that
it's not the case there even exists two
mechanisms each of them is predicating
out secure but when we put them together
they are not secure anymore
so now uh that we have this modeling i
would like to make some uh use of it and
we are going to ask with respect to the
two technologies
that we presented differential privacy
and canonity whether they provide
security against predicate signaling out
with respect to our differential privacy
we can prove
that any differentially private
mechanism is also
predicating out secure so here we get a
positive answer
with respect to cannonimity
we can ask the same question
and we can show uh that for a large
family which is actually quite typical
uh um family of can anonymizers
um
the can only master itself does the hard
work for the attacker the attacker
the the outcome of the cannon anonymizer
needs to be complimented with a trivial
attacker
and hence
a predicate singling out uh
that attacker manages to predicate
single out
so uh can amity
does not withstand
this requirement
but this uh these two questions were
with respect to this concept that i just
invented and told you about but the real
question is whether
these two technologies satisfy the
requirements of the general data
protection regulation okay
and
in order to answer this uh
we'll try to give a partial answer
so we'll first review some of the
modeling assumptions that we did and all
these modeling assumptions were kind of
chosen in order to weaken
the uh the concept of predicate
signaling out what do i mean by that
so we restricted the the concept in
several ways first
we only considered data that is selected
from some underlying distribution and
furthermore
the entries are independent from each
other
then
we only gave the attacker a the outcome
of the mechanism in the real world the
attacker usually comes with some other
knowledge which we call auxiliary
information but not in our definition
and lastly
we focused on the case where the
attacker
outputs
descriptions that have
very very small weight negligible weight
but it may be that
that that
in the real world or that the regulator
were also interested in other in other
more general uh
uh set of uh of
descriptions
so what we can conclude is that
our formulation is potentially weaker
than what the gdpr regulators had in
mind for singling out
okay
it means that failure to protect against
predicate singling out
likely implies failure to protect
against gdpr stingling out
so let's see how all these figures
together into what uh we call a legal
theorem okay so we need to bridge
between the two worlds on the left we
have computer science
on the right we have the law okay
on the legal side
uh we read from the gdpr that there is
that it is concerned with this notion of
singling out
and if you can single it out according
to the gdpr
then you fail to anonymize under the
on the gdpr side on the computer science
side
uh we showed things like the following
we presented a concept that we called
predicate singling out
and we demonstrated that the county
enables predicate signaling out
because the concept of predicate signing
out is potentially weaker than the gdpr
requirement
this implies
through this chain of reasonings that
can anonymity likely fails to anonymize
under the gdpr
with respect to differential privacy
we saw uh we can prove that it does not
enable on that it protects again
predicate signaling out
but this does not tell us yet whether
our differential privacy is sufficient
or insufficient for the gdpr
anonymization standard
going back to the article 29 party
assessment
we think and recommend that they that
they should reconsider their uh
uh determination with respect to
canonimity
and related technology like in diversity
so let me summarize what we've seen
we started from with the legal notion
with this little standard the gdpr
and from the gdpr we picked this notion
of singling out
uh we
tried to translate this concept into
mathematical language and we came up
with a definition of predicting out
security
okay
then um
we reasoned that um
trading singing out does not compose and
we think it
like if you follow the the also the
ideas of the proof it likely implies
that also the legal notion the gdpr
thing out and notion of figuring out
likely doesn't compose okay this is a
weakness does not mean that it's a bad
concept but probably means that it needs
to be complemented with other
requirements
then uh we looked at canon musician and
we showed that it is not pretty
significant secure
uh and we think that
this means that canon musician likely
does not prevent the gdpr notion of
singling out with differential privacy
we can prove that
it
prevents predicate signaling out this
gives some evidence that differential
privacy prevents the gdpr singling out
notion
but we need to further look into this
and lastly
uh it's interesting that we can also try
to
it would be interesting if if we would
take what we learned in in our technical
analysis and try to build a legal
concept based on it
and um
indeed in our writing we started working
on
providing legal language
that captures some of the understanding
that we
developed in this sport but there's
still a long way to go
thank you for listening